[Musik]
>> SALLY: Für die Muffins braucht ihr
12 Oreo Kekse,
150 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz,
160 Gramm Mehl,
40 Gramm Kakaopulver,
einen viertel Teelöffel Natron,
einen halben Teelöffel Backpulver,
zwei Eier,
60 Milliliter Buttermilch
und 150 Milliliter Speiseöl.
Ihr nehmt jetzt einfach die Kekse
und die werden jetzt erst mal zerkleinert.
Ich mache das jetzt in einem Gefrierbeutel
und kann jetzt hier in einer Rührschüssel
die trockenen Zutaten verrühren.
Jetzt kommen die flüssigen Zutaten rein.
Und jetzt werden die Zutaten einfach noch kurz verrührt.
Und wer möchte,
kann jetzt noch ein bisschen Espresso dazu geben.
Das mache ich jetzt auch
einfach für einen leckereren Geschmack.
Und jetzt nehme ich den Teig
und portioniere ihn mit einem Eisportionierer
in die zwölf Muffinförmchen.
[Musik]
Jetzt gebe ich die Himbeeren in einen Topf.
Dann etwas Zitronensaft.
Etwas Wasser zum Einkochen
und Puderzucker.
Die Himbeeren sind jetzt eingekocht
und jetzt werde ich sie durch ein Sieb streichen.
Während das hier jetzt noch abtropft,
– ich stelle es mal kurz zur Seite
und streiche es gleich fertig –
kann ich hier in einem Topf schon mal Isomalt schmelzen.
Das flüssige Glas, also das Isomalt, hier drauf,
damit es als eine Platte fest werden kann.
Und jetzt kann ich noch die Sahne unterheben.
Und jetzt werden die Cupcakes damit bespritzt.
[Musik]
Jetzt drüberfließen lassen.
Jetzt könnt ihr sie entweder so lassen
oder ihr steckt jetzt hier die Glassplitter rein
oder ihr nehmt zum Beispiel so eine Dekoration.
Finde ich auch ganz hübsch.
Vor allem die Messer und die Mumien
und auch die Gespenster und Geister
passen wirklich super dazu.
[Musik]
Für den Pie-Teig verwende ich
450 Gramm Mehl,
einen Teelöffel Zucker,
einen Teelöffel Salz,
drei Teelöffel Kokosöl,
225 Gramm eiskalte Butter,
60 Milliliter eiskaltes Wasser
und zwei Teelöffel Zitronensaft.
Ich stelle jetzt den Pie-Teig her.
Und da ist ganz wichtig, dass alle Zutaten sehr kalt sind.
Ich stelle auch die Butter immer
für eine halbe Stunde in den Gefrierschrank.
So ist sie wirklich eiskalt.
Und auch das Wasser ist eiskalt.
Jetzt kommt das Kokosöl rein,
[Musik]
die Butter in Stückchen.
Jetzt kommt das eiskalte Wasser dazu
und noch der Zitronensaft
und davon zwei Teelöffel.
[Musik]
Den Teig nehme ich jetzt
und gebe ihn hier auf die Arbeitsfläche.
Und danach muss ich ihn für zwei Stunden kühlen.
Und die Zeit kann ich dann ganz gut nutzen,
um die Füllung vorzubereiten.
[Musik]
Für die Füllung verwende ich
150 Gramm braunen Zucker,
200 Milliliter Kirschsaft,
200 Gramm Äpfel,
250 Gramm Hokkaido-Kürbis,
250 Gramm Kirschen aus dem Glas,
einen Teelöffel Zitronensaft,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
eine Prise Salz
und hier noch die Gewürze
Muskatnuss,
Zimt
und Ingwer,
zwei Teelöffel Stärke
und zwei Esslöffel Wasser.
[Musik]
Den Hokkaido-Kürbis finde ich ganz praktisch,
weil man ihn nicht schälen muss.
Also da wird die Schale auch richtig schön weich.
Und ich brauche ja davon jetzt nur 250 Gramm.
Jetzt geht es direkt an das Verarbeiten der Füllung.
Ich gebe jetzt zuerst den braunen Zucker in einen Topf
und lasse ihn darin karamellisieren.
Und zwar presse ich jetzt direkt auch den Zitronensaft
zu den Äpfeln und zum Kürbis dazu.
Dann kommen da die Gewürze mit rein,
Ingwer, Zimt,
ein bisschen Salz
und Muskatnuss frisch gerieben.
Und die Kirschen, die kann ich auch schon einrühren.
Jetzt kommt hier das ganze Obst mit rein mit dem Kürbis.
Jetzt ist der Pie-Teig gut durchgekühlt.
Und ich habe ihn jetzt auch schon mal gut durchgeknetet.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt hier Tarte-Formen mit Hebeboden,
damit ich einfach später die Tarte wieder gut rausbekomme.
Und jetzt könnt ihr hier die Gesichter reinmachen.
Und zwar nehme ich jetzt dafür einfach Lochtüllen
und kleine Ausstecher.
Und damit könnt ihr zum Beispiel
Gespenstergesichter machen
oder Kürbisse oder auch einen Totenkopf.
Jetzt nehme ich die abgekühlte Füllung
und die kommt jetzt einfach mittenrein.
Und jetzt können sie schon in den Backofen.
[Musik]
Für den Hefeteig brauche ich
einen Würfel Hefe,
200 Milliliter warmes Wasser,
30 Gramm Zucker,
30 Gramm Honig,
etwas schwarze Lebensmittelfarbpaste,
260 Gramm Buttermilch,
zwei Eier,
vier Teelöffel Salz,
160 Gramm flüssige Butter
und ein Kilo Mehl.
Zuerst löse ich jetzt die Hefe im Wasser auf
und füge den Zucker,
den Honig
und ein bisschen Lebensmittelfarbpaste hinzu.
Jetzt kommen noch die übrigen Zutaten,
also Buttermilch,
Eier,
Salz,
Mehl
und Butter mit dazu.
Also momentan sieht das Ganze
noch ein bisschen abgefahren aus.
Jetzt forme ich den Teig zu einer Kugel.
Da verwende ich jetzt nicht mehr so viel Mehl,
lege die Teigkugel hinein
und fette auch die Oberfläche, damit sie nicht trocknet.
Und ich kann jetzt den Teig abdecken
und für eine Stunde ruhen lassen.
Den gut aufgegangenen Teig portioniere ich jetzt
in 80 Gramm schwere Teiglinge.
Und die forme ich dann mit den Händen
zu richtig schönen glatten Kugeln.
Und nach dem Backen werden sie direkt
mit flüssiger Butter bestrichen.
Die Burger Buns sind jetzt fertig,
sind auch schon abgekühlt und sehen richtig gut aus.
Ich freue mich schon richtig auf einen Burger.
Jetzt werde ich noch die restlichen Zutaten vorbereiten.
Ich mache jetzt eine selbst gemachte Soße natürlich,
eine Hamburger-Soße.
Und ich werde noch ein bisschen Rote Bete
und Käse mit reingeben.
Zuerst nehme ich jetzt das Eigelb.
Da kommt jetzt
ein bisschen Tabasco dazu.
Ihr könnt auch gerne ein bisschen weniger nehmen.
Tabasco hat halt eine richtig schöne
und so ein bisschen säuerliche Schärfe.
Dann noch der halbe Zitronensaft.
Und ihr könnt im Prinzip auch schon
Salz, Zucker, Senf und Tomatenmark dazu geben.
Und jetzt das Eigelb erst mal cremig rühren.
Und hier gebe ich jetzt noch ein bisschen Pfeffer rein
und verrühre das Ganze
und schmecke einfach noch mal die Soße ab,
ob genug Zitronensaft drin ist und Tabasco und Salz.
Und dann kann ich die Soße
schon mal in den Kühlschrank stellen
und in der Zeit die Rote Bete vorbereiten.
Jetzt kann ich die kurz schälen.
Da kommt jetzt das Öl mit dazu.
Und jetzt kann ich die Rote Bete in der Pfanne anbraten
und werde sie dann gleich
mit dem Orangensaft abschmecken.
Und dann lasse ich den einfach verkochen.
Das heißt, es wird jetzt so lange noch weiter gerührt,
bis er verkocht ist.
Da kommt noch ein bisschen Kreuzkümmel rein
und etwas Salz und Pfeffer.
Jetzt geht es weiter mit den Zwiebeln.
Ich habe jetzt hier schon mal zwei Zwiebeln geschält.
Hier habe ich etwa 50 Gramm Mehl
und natürlich die wichtigste Zutat,
der Grillkäse.
Denn ohne Grillkäse wäre es natürlich kein Veggie-Burger.
Ich habe jetzt hier den Gazi-Grillkäse.
Den gibt es einmal in Natur, in Kräuter und Chili.
Und ich werde jetzt gleich einfach alle drei benutzen
und Murat darf dann einfach probieren,
welcher ihm am besten schmeckt.
Ich fange jetzt aber zuerst einmal mit der Zwiebel an.
Die könnt ihr jetzt entweder in feine Ringe schneiden
oder eben auch in Spiralen.
Und jetzt nehme ich einfach immer so ein Nest voll,
gebe es ins heiße Frittierfett.
Der Grillkäse wird dann einfach in die Pfanne gelegt
und von beiden Seiten etwa drei bis vier Minuten angebraten.
[Musik]
Für den Hefeteig verwende ich
einen Würfel Hefe,
zwei Esslöffel warmes Wasser,
50 Gramm Zucker,
350 Gramm Milch,
zwei Eier und zwei Eigelbe,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
800 bis 850 Gramm Mehl,
einen Teelöffel Salz und Zimt
und 70 Gramm weiche Butter.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Hefe aufgegangen
und ich kann den Teig fertigstellen.
Das heißt, ich gebe jetzt einfach alle Zutaten rein.
Beim Mehl mache ich es immer so:
erst mal nur ein bisschen mehr als die Hälfte.
Die Eier und das Eigelb.
Da habe ich jetzt einfach
mein Basis-Donut-Rezept genommen
und noch mit Zimt verfeinert.
Heute geht es ja mehr um die Deko und um die Füllung.
Vanilleextrakt ist noch drin
und die Milch.
Die habe ich bereits erwärmt.
Dafür könnt ihr nämlich einfach
das Emailleschälchen auf den Herd stellen,
kurz erwärmen
und dann die Milch direkt reingeben.
Dann anschalten.
Jetzt wird der Teig richtig schön geknetet
und ich kann jetzt nach und nach
noch das restliche Mehl dazu geben.
Jetzt noch die Butter mit dazu.
Ich gebe den Teig darauf
und forme ihn jetzt einfach kurz zu einer Kugel.
Ihr seht auch, der klebt jetzt nicht mehr.
Und jetzt lasse ich den Teig schön aufgehen.
Und jetzt überlege ich mir noch eine Füllung.
Denn ich hätte gerne, dass die Donuts
eine richtig leckere Füllung haben.
Dafür nehme ich
250 Gramm Himbeeren,
250 Gramm Johannisbeeren.
Die sind aus dem Tiefkühlfach,
denn jetzt bekommt man sie einfach nicht mehr
regional und frisch.
Dann habe ich hier
50 Gramm Stärke
und 100 Gramm Zucker.
Den Zucker, den könnt ihr natürlich auch variieren,
weniger oder mehr nehmen,
je nachdem, wie süß einfach die Früchte sind.
Jetzt gebe ich einfach alle Zutaten hier in einen Topf
und erhitze das Ganze jetzt erst mal auf niedriger Stufe,
damit die Früchte einfach auch schön auftauen können.
[Musik]
Jetzt nehme ich den Teig heraus
und kann ihn auf 1 cm Stärke ausrollen.
Ich steche jetzt hier die Donuts aus,
zuerst außen
und dann innen.
[Musik]
Die Donuts sind jetzt aufgegangen.
Und ich werde sie jetzt hier in der Fritteuse frittieren
– das seht ihr auch alles in meinem Grundrezeptvideo –
bei 150 bis 160°C,
also wirklich nicht zu heiß.
Einen Kochtopf könnt ihr auch nehmen,
aber wirklich nicht zu heiß einstellen.
Die Donuts sind jetzt fertig.
Den restlichen Teig backe ich gerade noch aus
so als Minikrapfen.
Und ich lasse die jetzt hier abkühlen
und werde sie danach dann befüllen und dekorieren.
[Musik]
Für den Rührteig verwende ich
200 Gramm weiche Butter,
200 Gramm Zucker
und eine Prise Salz,
100 Gramm Marzipanrohmasse,
etwas Bittermandelaroma,
vier Eier,
– die sind zimmerwarm –
200 Gramm Mandeln,
– die werde ich gleich noch fein mahlen –
200 Gramm Mehl,
ein Päckchen Backpulver
– das sind drei Teelöffel –
und 125 Gramm lauwarme Milch.
Die Mandeln werden jetzt fein gemahlen.
Wenn ihr die Mandeln dann gemahlen habt,
könnt ihr bereits den Rührteig herstellen.
Jetzt einfach die Butter mit dem Zucker verrühren.
Eine Prise Salz noch dazu.
Ich gebe zum Verstärken des Amaretto-Geschmacks,
also des Mandelgeschmacks,
noch ein paar Tropfen Bittermandelaroma dazu.
Jetzt hier für etwa zwei bis drei Minuten verrühren
oder vier bis fünf, bis es eben schön weißcremig ist.
Und jetzt gebe ich hier nacheinander die Eier dazu.
Immer ein Ei rein, eine halbe Minute einrühren
und dann erst das nächste.
So gerinnt der Rührteig nicht.
Und jetzt kommt alles nacheinander rein.
Und jetzt wirklich nur noch kurz rühren.
Sonst wird der Teig nämlich speckig.
Die Milch ist auch lauwarm.
Das Mehl dazu und die Mandeln.
Und dann kommt der direkt in den Backring rein.
Den habe ich bereits auf 24 cm Durchmesser eingestellt.
Dann so ein bisschen verteilen.
Und ich streiche den Teig immer gern am Rand etwas hoch.
So backt er gleichmäßiger.
Die Torte werde ich mit einer Marmelade füllen
und einer Ganache.
Da mache ich jetzt einfach eine Zartbitter-Ganache
und zwar die Ganache zum Befüllen,
das heißt 300 Gramm Sahne
und 600 Gramm Zartbitterschokolade.
Die Sahne wird jetzt einmal kurz aufgekocht.
Dann schalte ich den Herd aus
und dann rühre ich die Schokolade ein.
Ich nehme jetzt hier den Kuchen heraus.
Der ist schön abgekühlt.
Ich habe ihn direkt im Ring abkühlen lassen.
Zum Füllen schneide ich den Kuchen jetzt mal durch.
Und da nehmt ihr entweder eine Tortensäge
oder einfach ein Tortenmesser.
Der erste Boden kommt jetzt direkt drauf.
Und jetzt könnt ihr ihn
entweder komplett mit der Ganache füllen
oder noch eine Marmelade nehmen.
Jetzt nehme ich die Vorlage.
Jetzt habe ich sie mittlerweile mit Augen.
Okay. Jetzt schneide ich hier einmal außen herum.
Okay. Das lasse ich jetzt kurz fest werden
und dann kann ich wieder weiter schneiden.
Und das Gesicht ist natürlich
in der Mitte bei der Nase am höchsten
und geht dann auch so ein bisschen nach außen.
Und überall da, wo ich markante Gesichtszüge habe,
schneide ich sie natürlich ein.
Und die Ganache hier nehme ich jetzt,
um das Ganze dreidimensional zu formen und zu glätten.
Das heißt, ich streiche die immer wieder auf,
setze ein bisschen Teig drauf, schneide was weg
und so entsteht jetzt gleich die Gesichtsform.
Und ich habe jetzt hier noch etwas Modelliermarzipan,
also Dekor-Marzipan.
Da ist jetzt egal, welche Farbe ihr nehmt.
Und damit könnt ihr nämlich Gesichtszüge
und die Nase zum Beispiel richtig gut formen.
Das heißt, ich nehme ein kleines Stück in die Hand,
schaue immer wieder auf die Vorlage,
platziere es
und dann einfach mit den Händen schön drücken.
Und jetzt sieht das echt noch etwas seltsam aus,
aber gleich mit der Fondantschicht drüber
wird es gleich gut.
Okay. Jetzt ist der Fondant dran.
Ich habe jetzt hier ein bisschen Weiß und Grün.
Und ich rolle jetzt den Fondant auf etwas Bäckerstärke aus.
Jetzt nur über das Gesicht legen.
Denn die Haare, die werden ja gleich grün.
Ich schneide jetzt hier am Haaransatz entlang.
Lieber erst mal ein bisschen mehr dran lassen
als zu viel wegschneiden.
[Musik]
Und jetzt nehme ich Modellierwerkzeug
und gehe jetzt hier einfach komplett in die Falten rein,
werde die Nase schön ausmodellieren.
Und da braucht ihr einfach ein bisschen Geduld.
Aber je detaillierter, umso besser.
Jetzt stelle ich die Torte kurz zur Seite
und kann etwas Grün ausrollen.
Also drüberlegen.
Und der Fondant lässt sich auch echt gut ziehen.
Der ist schön elastisch.
Die Feinheiten schneide ich dann mit dem Cutter weg,
mit dem scharfen Messer.
Ich glaube, das sieht schon mal ganz gut aus.
Jetzt kommt noch eine Haarsträhne.
Die hängt ihm ja so ein bisschen ins Gesicht.
Und die fängt hier hinten an,
kommt hier rüber.
Ja.
Jetzt nehme ich schwarze Pulverfarbe
und schattiere jetzt damit das Gesicht.
[Musik]
So gefällt sie mir schon ziemlich gut.
Das Einzige, was ich jetzt noch mache, sind die Lichtpunkte.
Die mache ich jetzt mit der Zuckerschrift in Weiß.
[Musik]